all right
to get a shot like this from Shang Chi
Hollywood primes cars like this one to
get crushed dramatically on camera
and that work is up to the team at gem
FX which sets cars up for optimal
destruction in movies like Shang Chi
taken three
and Ghostbusters afterlife
we visited gem to see how it designs
cars to get spectacularly destroyed on
screen exactly as planned
in real life cars don't always get
destroyed in the most cinematic ways
even when hit repeatedly a car roof
won't always cave in on itself like
we're used to seeing in movies that's
where scoring comes in stripping away
the protective sheet metal in a car and
gutting it of its support we're going to
start by cutting this pillar from here
to here to basically weaken the
structure
thank you
so now that we've finished our cut we're
going to take a pry bar and simply
remove this small chunk
of the front a pillar
each cut determines where and how the
car will fold we're going to go through
and do some weakening cuts to help this
fold a little bit easier under a little
less weight they target the a b and c
pillars of the car now when you're doing
this you have to ensure not to cut the
outside of the vehicle because then it'd
be visible and you could tell something
is up with it so we like to try and hide
all of our stuff then they put the whole
thing back together so we're going to
start out by reconnecting our wire
harness
then we'll take our interior cover put
it back on replace our weather stripping
and now we're back to the stock interior
it looks like a normal car from the
inside but it will crush it took four
hours to score the car also it could be
destroyed in seconds by a 3 000 pound
weight and the areas they scored were
the ones that folded cleanly
the team at gem doesn't go all the way
with the scoring process for every job
take this bus crash in shangji this shot
was filmed on location in San Francisco
and the parked cars getting run over are
real gem prepped them for Destruction
the cars were supposed to get crushed in
the bus's path but they also needed to
be strong enough to slow down the bus so
gem only scored the upper portion of the
vehicles to collapse on impact keeping
the lower portions strong when the bus
would carry over the tops of the
vehicles if it went down too far scene
wouldn't look right so all we wanted is
just so much compression and actually
provide a flat platform for the camera
to track down the hill with they can
also just focus on a few major points of
weakening like these hinges on car doors
swapping up the steel hinges for
Breakaway ones makes the doors
incredibly easy to rip off they're made
out of a weaker compound which makes
them sheer easier so that way it'll snap
the door off nice and easy then they cut
these white is to make sure the door has
nothing to hang on to after the bolts
blow out these weaker materials allow
for big results
[Music]
some forms of damage can be faked like
for scenes where an actor crashes into
something and the hood of their car
dramatically pops up
the team at gem can rig hoods to do that
on cue
so that hood popping rig basically we
took a stock Crown Vic hood and we went
inside we actually scored it to a point
so that way when we put a cylinder on it
and we pulled it it just bent just like
you know soft metal they were able to do
this over and over again on the same
Hood reusing it through the whole night
of shooting the shop used a similar
technique to rig this truck and
Ghostbusters afterlife and the storyline
was the ghost is chasing this truck and
he's punching at the truck they had to
make the doors Dent practically as if
the ghost who would be added with CG was
crashing into it to get the effect in
camera elia's team replicated the door
panels of the GMC pickup in a soft
conditioned aluminum and attach the
panels to a rig that made them buckle on
cue so that when we pulled over the
pneumatic RAM on the inside it sucked it
in and looked like the ghost was
punching these these panels
the work isn't limited to the car itself
jumbles all sorts of tricks on set to
make sure destruction goes according to
plan with ramps
cannons
[Music]
and cables
in our world you only get so many
seconds to tell the story so they want
to make a dramatic cars don't always
just explode on impact so gem gives them
a little help
so what we'll do is use devices
everything from a gas bomb underneath
the vehicle or to a what's called a
propane popper and attaches to the
vehicle we'll have it fired whether it's
on a wire remote control or an impact
switch or sometimes even the stunt guy
will have the button inside with him to
make cars go flying at the Press of a
button the shop retrofits cars with
different types of cannons like on this
test run for which the team was asked to
split a truck in half they built a 10
inch dual Cannon system to pull it off
and used this system on a larger scale
for this highway chase and taken 3. you
had to start with tractor trailer coming
down the highway having a jackknife so
much impact that it caused the sea
container to fall off the trailer so
much speed that when it did hit the
ground it rolled and ran over cars to
execute the move they used two 12-inch
nitrogen cannons which provided enough
inertia to flip the trailer shipping
container and for the rolling part we
welded Wheels on the end of the square
seat container so we could roll it down
the highway way a carefully placed ramp
can also make cars flip in ways they
would never do on their own
cap then the angle the kicker at the end
is what will send the car spiraling and
flipping over at speed reductions hide
ramps on The Blind Side of cars and also
use set decoration like roadblocks
when a destruction scene calls for a car
to follow a very specific trajectory the
job often involves cable rigs which can
make the cars crash or spin in a
predetermined fashion
gem builds cable accelerators to pull
heavy vehicles in a desired Direction
fast
and limiting or suspender cables make
cars come to a full halt within a split
second something you can't do with
regular car brakes
they used these cables in bright David
air wanted us to have a Suburban come in
hit this imaginary wall and stop on a
dime and it was all shot very very
stylistic so you had a side profile and
picks up the crumpling of the hood so
what we did is we built a pull Cable
forward but we also had a stop cable
going to the front of those as a bumper
we actually scored and weakened the
front so we collapsed it back and held
the vehicle from Crossing that imagineer
barrier cables also help gem execute one
of its most customized crash jobs for
velvet Buzz saw the truck had to slam
into the corner of this building that
was a real building so we couldn't hurt
the real building and the car could only
get hit in a precise area on the
passenger door so that the audience
would believe the driver survived to
pull it off Jem built a whole new set
element the team structurally embedded a
fake pole that was strong enough to
absorb the impact of the car a fake hole
that's in there hard enough that it
didn't move and give away that it was a
fake pole and over the car doors placed
an outer layer made from soft
conditioned aluminum this would help
them show more impact with less brick
rash that might look random and chaotic
Jen's team will spend hours testing and
experimenting to make sure everything
happens exactly how they want it to and
even if it isn't realistic it sure looks
like it everything we do defies physics
none of it makes sense but we get paid
to do it
[Music]